on va faire pour la première fois en
martinique on va chanter antoine y
entraîner c'est ce morceau de bravoure
que que paulo avait commencé à réaliser
il voulait faire une comédie musicale
sur la relation entre un couple enfin
bon truc qui était très bon ya pas eu le
temps de le faire mais entraîner c'est
un morceau de 8 9 minutes et orale fait
mention ce renvoi enfin c'est une
dispute quoi en fait
et on l'a jamais fait sur scène on l'a
fait en guadeloupe une fois mais on n'a
jamais fait en martinique donc ce sera
une première il ya plein de gens que je
rencontre me lisa ou café antoine
jusqu'à fin août
donc ça c'est un moment c'est un moment
voilà c'est un moment important parce
que c'est la première fois qu'on le fait
sur scène et
et puis bon voilà c'est aussi un hommage
quand un polo parce que paul hausse
quand même un des plus grands musiciens
de cette époque des composés des grands
compositeurs et indépendant arrangeur
parce que pente ferries arrangements et
violent qu'il a fait il faut vraiment
écouter les morceaux arrangés par paulo
il fait pas mal à voir parce que c'est
ce sont des pépites des pépites
musicales
donc c'est plus côté on a plus
d'oreilles pour écouter mais il faut
écouter parce qu'on avait la chance
d'avoir cet homme-là qui étaient avec
nous qu'ils étaient voilà et cafés etc a
laissé un héritage absolument fabuleux
donc très contente d'être là il n'y aura
pas content il ya bien sûr l'éternel
caresser mois là aussi pour lui avait
fait un arrangement génial ainsi c'est
une proposition nouvelle proposition que
j'ai faite un peu en pensant beaucoup à
ralph et c'est moi qui vais la chanter
mais je pense qu'on va la récupérer un
jour est plutôt maline donc et puis il a
pas que moi il y aura bien sûr y'a
pipeau y arrive car il ya un mort lan et
à laurianne enfin bon ça va être un
concert sympa
donc on fait ça deux jours